phase I required boshy and impact ozz
but you know he does first but they're
all see that under the torres piglet got
jumped the waters on them in there now
absolutely running for the fountain this
does not look good for royal this
doesn't engage crescendo judges all of
them it's a double for in fight they get
on the fountain here comes the battle
back and fans gonna lose his life both
junglers now dead for be freebus through
these in turn they've got to be careful
double to clean it up there comes the
damage shop with smooth lines still
hasn't tied but Apollo's gone somehow
hiding away from somebody oh my god
[Applause]
that is ridiculous he just goes top died
and then he hits a solo kill song impact
on young was born in March 1995 in South
Korea and was an early adopter to League
of Legends playing on the North American
server before the Korean Won was
released but once it was released in
December 2011 his talent attracted
attention he first joined zenyk storm as
a support player in 2012 where he helped
them qualify for the upcoming OGN spring
season xenyx made a deep run in that
inaugural champions tournament losing an
extremely close semi-final to MIG Frost
[Applause]
they won the third place match against
topi finishing their first season in
third and regrouped for summer but after
storms run in the summer ended in the
quarterfinals impact entered a period of
roster turbulence
he left senex to play for tempest but
that roster was eventually acquired by
Centex but by February 2013 impact left
the org for good and found a new team
impact found a place on SK Telecom t1
twos newly formed roster and having
switched to top lane near the end of his
time with xenix
he'd stay in that role with SKT it was
clear almost immediately that SKT had
something special in that roster a
double-kill actually for impact playing
alongside bengi faker piglet and
poohmandu SKT t1 2 placed 3rd in the
spring but came into their own by the
time summer started and in a dazzling
final outside the Jamsil Olympic Stadium
in Seoul in August 2013 impact won his
first OGN title impact played well in
that series showing that he was a
top-level player in his position but his
performance was somewhat obscured by one
of his teammates growing shadow faker
baby in trouble you're dead Bart price
to clean it up for you
oh look at the class look at the boat
thank you well I was that Baker with a
you I play the qss I can't spell J by
artist oh yeah actually what that jewel
I guess
to the Katy bullets bass oh wow can you
say with rivals kt rolster bullets
missing out on the world championship
that year impact an sk telecom t1 k
looked like the strongest korean team
headed to the year's biggest tournament
[Music]
SKT entered the group stage ready to
assert their dominance but they were
surprised by the quality of teams that
they faced early on they would call big
a oh you got tell my son de tomar una
god mode attempt is ago a man hugging
and chemical and when they dropped a
group stage game to china's OMG SKT the
strongest team heading into the
tournament realize that they needed to
get serious that this was no vacation
that she would yogi was a definite
o'banion mana and a pump will go by now
it's all too
SKT exited the group stage seven and one
and in the quarterfinals they matched up
against one of four teams seated
directly into the bracket the Khomeini
ABARES they dispatched the 2-0 you know
has been caught he's been kicked back
with that they're now dead to rights now
snake will be the next ones are for who
gets a kill credit it's Baker and piglet
picks up his second now wins is getting
dropped down has sought out the
background is correct a clean ace for
SKT and they're gonna close this game
out so far SKT had only dropped one game
throughout the tournament but they faced
a serious obstacle in the semi violence
najin sword the winners of champions
winter 2012-2013 nausea and qualified
directly for the quarterfinals at Worlds
so by the time SKT sat down to face them
they have little recent information on
SKT - on the president choi hyung-woo
sake point - yes I did with the Cobra
tape yes and perhaps because of that
unfamiliarity it was a closed series
from the get-go that leaves us at 2-2
now we're gonna go into the last game is
anyone's SKT got off to an early lead
thanks to superior laning and an edge in
objectives but nausea and continued to
apply pressure with their pick focused
calm in the end SKT superior team
fighting was too much for nausea and
they ended the game quickly off the back
of the wanting clean fight yeah he's all
shook up break prey still alive as the
counter-strike doesn't land a good job
that we've lifted trouble he uses the
our kinship board he secured another
kill as not based on the retreat not
make it tough
expecially Trump still in trouble and
he's a last mono and this one is
impacting a diamond who was the first
time since the Korean summer final that
SKT had really been tested for roster
with young players many and their first
year of competitive play they were able
to stay calm and composed and they
dismantled Naja in the clutch there was
one series left between impact SKT and
history one stage and it would be one of
eSports biggest to date though season
two's World Championship had been one of
the biggest eSports events held in the
West ever at the time season three's
offering was on a completely different
scale and it was in a packed staple
center to the roar of thousands of fans
that impact on his team played for an
engraving on the summoner's Cup though
impact was no stranger to playing in
front of large crowds this would be his
biggest so far and in the lead-up to the
finals SK T's players were candid about
some nerves related to the big series
and a garlic honky Tonk a clinic in
jungle [ __ ] gonna go good bail
I tied that acting technical as you go
their opponents in the final were Royal
Club a Chinese team that bulldozed oMG
and fnatic on their way to the finals
the teams big personalities and today's
English interviews first of all hello
guys a la vallee quickly made them a fan
favorite but it wasn't just popular
perception Royals clean dismantling of
oMG and fnatic the other two teams to go
7 and 1 in groups convinced many
analysts of their strengths I'm gonna
I'm gonna have to go ahead
loyal as well boil all the way lots of
kills back and forward but it's SK
Telecom's second gate to the wall finals
after going up 2-0 against royal SKT
looked set to sweep the series as far as
impact was concerned once they locked in
jacks one of his signature picks the
tournament was his piglet got jump the
waters on them in there now absolutely
running for the fountain this does not
look good for royal this doesn't it
crescendo judges all the limits a double
for in fight they get on the bouncing SK
Telecom I'll just roll is through the
Nexus turrets are potentially going to
go down this could be a 20 minute they
will be the season three champions here
at the Staples Center in the end
wolves 2013 belong to Korea it belonged
to SKT it belonged to impact for impact
and the rest of SKT standing on that
stage and hoisting that trophy was the
culmination of their career so far but
they wanted more and they got it SKT
went undefeated in the group stage of
champions winter 2013 2014 they swept
Samsung blue in the quarterfinals they
swept the kt rolster bullets in the semi
finals
then they swept Samsung ozone in the
finals
15 and 0 in six series it's still the
only perfect season in the history of
Korean league SKT were on top of the
world but it was the last time impact
would taste success in Korea 2014 was a
slump here for SKT although 2013 had
been all about the mechanical prowess of
SKT stars to new rosters had begun to
rise to prominence ones with the
mechanics and team play to surpass sk p
samsung blue and samsung ozone later
samsung ye were two of the strongest
rosters in the world in 2014 and the
latter knocked SKT out of champions
spring and summer in the quarter-finals
both times then SKT missed out on worlds
after losing to a surging Nadja and
white shield in the regional finals SKT
didn't even get a chance to defend their
world championship fans of the team had
begun to see some of the players as
deadweight Baker would still a god but
his teammates couldn't keep up and
though impact played well in the series
against white shield there was a clear
sense that changes needed to be made at
the same time riot Korea announced that
they would be removing sister teams for
the 2015 season and as some teams
consolidated their rosters there was
also a huge surge of players leaving
Korea as stars from league's top region
sought glory and money abroad impact was
one of them according to reports at the
time impact chose to leave the roster
and he said that he was ready for
something new o I've done my booth with
touch America
hey young foolish Paco we were done we
go gay chuckle cut to another to another
nothing the cutting I get to a cool
he joined team impulse and got off to a
decent start with his new team finishing
the regular season in fourth place with
an 11 and 7 record they lost to team
solomid in the play-off semi-finals then
to Team Liquid in the third-place match
to finish the spring and fourth impulse
played high kill entertaining games
often with off meta picks like yas whoa
fizz and Lisa but even as he embraced
and enabled his team's chaotic play
style impact was a stable force in the
top the first time in his career he was
not overshadowed by mechanical prodigies
instead he was the veteran presence
among a group of relatively
inexperienced players though he was
still working on English impact had
quietly become more than just one of the
mechanically strongest hops in na by the
end of summer
he was also learning to put his
overconfident pass behind him and become
a leader at first it's kind of
intimidating but I do have a lot of
respect for him he has a lot of like
knowledge he's really like patient with
the game so it's been like quite a big
learning experience for me it's okay
though to consider biasing there's a lot
of monocots as you want I'm heading into
playoffs in summer 2015 tip were
legitimate contender they finished the
regular season in third place at 12 and
6 they're wild and unpredictable style
had allowed them to take wins off of
teams trying through a more standard
style and their powerful solo lanes and
impact and jiaojiao world
Adrian impacted Apollo all inside the
bear pit do what they can now just on
the entrance say fish this is a big
focus now over on to rush and impact
they're on the Keane but after Zhao Zhao
was banned due to Hilo boosting impulses
unpredictable style wasn't enough
they lost to CLG and the semi-finals and
Team Liquid in the third place match
Impulse finished fourth again it was
enough to earn impact and company a spot
in the regional gauntlet for impact it
was a chance for him to make it back to
Worlds
to stand on that stage one more time and
it started off well but after a reverse
sweep at the hands of cloud 9 who were
on their way to a miraculous run to
Worlds Impulse finished short of a spot
on the world stage for impact it was the
second time in a row
he'd been eliminated in the gauntlet
falling just shy of a world's berth
impact joined a new team energy esports
in november but despite a relatively
strong start to the split energy failed
to make much of a splash and were
eliminated in the quarterfinals though
impact had earned the respect of north
american fans he had yet to really prove
himself he might have been seen as one
of Enys strongest top laners but he had
yet to play for one of any strongest
teams it was time for another change it
was on cloud 9 that impact cemented
himself as one of the strongest top
laners in the region and impacts
dominant laning helped to coin a new
phrase he just goes top die and then he
gets a solo kills
I don't know he's really good and
throughout the end of the split impact
was making waves again for his stellar
individual plays with the team
prompting analysts and players to Herald
him as the region's best top laner this
time impact wasn't eliminated early in
the playoffs and cloud 9 made it to the
finals the series was close so far so
good for Cassiopeia Fox that stays alive
dodges the snipe and the fight is in
speak with hurricane looking for damage
there's a flash mock-up they're gonna go
for bio crush that will be TSM VS
forward
down they find one they're looking for
Jim Furyk since got up there's two 4972
on the scoreboard right now looking
towards Baron but in the end TSM was
able to clutch the series out TSM submit
themselves as the most dominant
organization North American League of
Legends and win their fourth North
American Championship
this time after defeating team envyus
and immortals in the regional gauntlet
impact was able to secure a spot at the
World Championship his first time back
at the game's biggest stage since he won
it in 2013
hey guys kiss disappear tomorrow you
could read about the charity connect I
just wanna tell the championship can i
oniy in of the sunday cloud 9 landed in
a rough group at Worlds 2016 facing off
against SK Telecom t1 I may and flash
wolves with SKT a clear favorite to make
it out of the group cloud nine were
expected to struggle to find a second
seed this was especially true against
the Taiwanese players on flash wolves
who had built up a formidable reputation
at international events but the group
stage draw meant something else for
impact he would face off against his old
teammates his old coach he would play
against the organization that made his
career good tone to new user more teen
anthems and cousin goes on unita unequal
play they've already killed off smoothly
that's not enough here for c9 sneaky
getting caught out he's in danger he can
go tab that he does Blanc is on a
rampage to 4-0 but now a double kill for
Bane make it three already it's gonna
lose it and impact is not gonna be
enough a single kill doesn't matter
enough sure he walks away but SKT in
complete control looking to close out
the game in the end SKT beat cloud 9 in
both their group stage games but thanks
to some struggles from flash wolves and
consistent play on cloud 9 sparked the
NA team was able to secure the second
seed to quarterfinals with a 3 and 3
record in quarterfinals cloud 9 faced
off against eventual finalist Samsung
Galaxy and we're dismantled 3 to 0 cloud
9 were not expected to win they went
further than any other na team at the
tournament but against one of the best
teams in the world they couldn't hold on
look at back at how they really got here
an impact was playing so good in the top
lane and teams made sure to shut that
down as much as they could and it
definitely seemed like that's what cloud
9 was lacking the fact that impact
couldn't get going again not saying it's
his fault teams were made sure that
impact could have get going again it
might have been a decent performance for
na on the international stage but for
impact it was another year without an NA
LCS title and another year without any
notable results on the international
stage in spring 2017 cloud 9 came close
again they placed second in the regular
season with impact taking 11 player of
the game Awards tied for second with
hauntzer
just behind dart aux 12 but after making
their way to another finals against TSM
they fell in a close 3-2 series to miss
out on msi and in the summer split cloud
9 faltered heartbreak for cloud line
this is the game that clouded a 10,000
gold lead and three debt inhibitors and
a full ville Tristana
and they failed to attack Nexus turrets
to play it right to close the game their
kings got caught out shove into the
fight yet again
TSM hoisted the trophy while cloud nine
were forced to play in the regional
finals were shot at worlds this time
cloud nine had to make it through the
play in stage where they swept their
group and qualifier match without
dropping a game he's obliterated double
kill for jensen trip roofing himself on
this one triple kill exactly and he's
gonna take down the Nexus c9 it was more
difficult this time but then our four
know in the group but once they
qualified for the main event impact and
the rest of cloud 9 faced stiff
competition with shades of 2016 they
once again had to face SKT
along with tough international teams in
Edward gaming and HQ eSports Club once
again cloud 9 made it out with a 3 and 3
record as the second seed once again
they were the only na team to advance to
the top 8 this time though cloud 9
wouldn't be facing off against a top
Korean team they were seated against
world elite a Chinese roster that has
showed strong results in groups but who
looked mortal cloud 9 had a fighting
chance and they knew it the series went
back and forth with everything coming
down to a pivotal game fun
first I'm going to try and get the oven
set the pen Mosu not enough is now
missing the next target Jensen he's also
you can see it minute sir chocolate
butter part off the mystic pot i crowd
man they get looking for the third
though get it all but world elite was
able to push a mid game lead to a huge
gold advantage and in the end how nine
couldn't plush the series
- its Doric semi-final
for impact it was the end of his third
year in North America and after two
quarterfinal exits at Worlds and too
many almost sin the NA LCS it was clear
that something had to change the end of
2017 signaled a new franchise era in
North America and with big money flowing
into the scene there was a huge turnover
in rosters orgs vied for top talent to
secure the best possible franchise team
for themselves and after three splits
with cloud nine impact moved to a new
roster Team Liquid attracted a lot of
attention heading into the spring split
impact join TL alongside former CLG
corps expel Beltre and double left and
Korean support Ola
it was a roster that boasted proven
synergy and very strong lanes people
expected Team Liquid to dominate and
this roster officially built one that's
why doing it the regular season saw some
stumbles and you can see impact
devastate and despite a strong start by
the end of the split Team Liquid were
caught in a convoluted tie near the top
of the standings
they entered playoffs and quarterfinals
with a lot of questions about their play
but those questions were dismissed
almost immediately
continues well for liquid two kills
already doubled getting a double for
himself Estonians pop all season long it
was clear the team liquid had the talent
to win in fact taking some damage here
to this one I don't they can get away
with this he's gonna fight a little bit
with the shield on you buy some time
he's doing real good with that but his
health and that is ridiculous they
dissemble the roster stacked with
individual talent but until playoffs
they'd been unable to capitalize on
their potential and they peaked at the
right time he's gonna follow the doublet
and look at the shutdown as Jensen's
gone second having her own not hitting
his shot living the teamfight licorice
gonna be not long for the world either
the chase almost there oh they lost a
blank up in the end only one team stood
between liquid and the NA LCS trophy 100
thieves liquid were able to ride the
momentum Baron what corner HP very very
good lesson he wanted to go over the
wall
and the rest of the series was about one
team and one team only the Nexus is
exposed that thieves are on the retreat
and liquid is looking to take this to
match point right here right now stick
around with the bots they're gonna make
smithy able to go and we'll find the
bull destroy is Ryu and that's what your
Garry's already out of the picture 100
thieves and some trouble gonna be taken
even lower half bubble already taken
down double Frick down the lift and the
thieves are triple liquid we'll look to
win right here champions liquid
dominated the rest of the finals and as
confetti rain down on them impact was
elated after more than three years in
North America and so many close but not
quite the win was impacts first title
since champions winter 2013 2014 in the
four and a half years since then he
moved across the world developed his
skills become a leader learned a new
language and made many many top laners
dive his peers in the NA LCS had come to
revere him as one of the best tops to
ever play in the region there's no
question that impact has already
cemented his place in league's history
books impact has evolved from a brash
young player to a mature veteran
presence who's capable of fitting into
any team but he'd never been able to
hoist that trophy never conquered his
region but on that hot day in Florida
impact was back on top thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button